um one other uh protein question that
came my way it came from social media i
forget exactly who asked it
um but i'm basically using it purely to
prove a point
i'm being too honest today aren't i uh
using it to reinforce a point but i will
answer the question uh
so
the question was there was a new study
that came out showing that higher
protein intake uh in the form of
essential amino acid supplementation i
believe
did not lead to higher
rates of muscle protein synthesis during
energy restriction
so does this mean that our protein needs
are unchanged by caloric restriction
regardless of the magnitude of the
energy deficit and you know this was
something that surprised readers because
uh you know the general kind of typical
advice is if you're going to be in a big
deficit you might want to bump up
protein a little bit you know if you're
especially if you're very lean in a big
deficit protein needs will probably bump
up a little bit
um
what was really interesting is you look
at the study and muscle protein
synthesis rates uh were not different
but
whole body protein balance was we there
was a collection of different
measurements they took to to approximate
you know what's our balance here of
anabolic catabolic processes related to
body protein and the last sentence of
the paper itself is
taken together
these results suggest that higher
essential amino acid doses are necessary
to optimize both muscle and whole body
protein status during the catabolic
stress of underfeeding
and
you listen to that statement and you
contrast it with the finding that
energy restriction did not appear to to
or you know high versus low protein in
the in the uh case of this energy
restriction
it didn't seem to matter for muscle
protein synthesis rates and yet the
take-home point was you're going to want
to bump up your protein if you're
restricting energy and i think
that
that contrast
throws a lot of people for a loop and i
think it highlights a really critical
distinction between
looking at muscle protein synthesis
and assuming that it absolutely
necessarily represents long-term
hypertrophy i think a lot of people have
gotten it in their mind if something
increases muscle protein synthesis if a
increases mps more than b does then a is
better for hypertrophy period i have the
proof it's data right
but
there are many instances in the
literature where that doesn't work out
it breaks down and if you were to
interpret
some of these muscle protein synthesis
papers at face value you would make uh
some conclusions that are erroneous they
they don't it's not just that they
didn't pan out it's that they don't have
face validity on their surface they
don't seem right because they aren't
right so like you could look at acute
muscle protein synthesis data
and there's literally a paper that would
indicate if taken at face value
that for an obese individual
doing a unilateral study design
their leg that doesn't lift
should grow more muscle than their leg
that does
no one would accept that at face value
but if you look at the way the muscle
protein synthesis data is presented that
is the conclusion you'd you'd have to
draw if you're taking it at face value
and you're assuming muscle protein
synthesis equals hypertrophy yeah that
was that was one of the studies that we
talked about during the whole p ratio
back and forth
exactly yeah and i said i i will accept
that argument if you if you believe
that the non-lifting leg should grow
more muscle than the lifting leg i've
never met anyone that would take that at
face value right so you have to check
yourself with some of these
interpretations and make sure that if
you're going to take it at phase out you
have to take all of it at face value you
know
uh
there there are similar um situations
with some of the
research looking at plant versus animal
protein sources where you'll look at
you know acute muscle protein synthesis
data and say there is an enormous
difference between these protein sources
like this animal-based protein source
should should promote so much more
hypertrophy than this plant-based source
but then when we put them in the context
of you know whether we're looking at
individual supplement interventions or
entire diets
that difference that seems huge at the
level of muscle protein synthesis
really shrinks when you start looking at
actual hypertrophy measurements over
time
a different example is with raw versus
cooked eggs i think it's
generally accepted maybe research will
uh change our perspective on this in the
future but my general understanding is
that raw albumin from egg is far less
digestible than cooked albumen
that's my understanding that that i've
seen in in studies i mean that that
wasn't rocky's understanding but that
was not i mean there there are differing
opinions we just want to make it clear
this isn't settled science right uh
you know
academic research says one thing uh
balboa at all have some some differing
opinions so do do with that what you
will yeah but i mean we're talking about
a difference on the order of like 90
versus 50
digestibility big
uh and then a paper comes out showing
absolutely no difference in muscle
protein synthesis right and so
we have to be very cautious when we
interpret muscle protein synthesis
findings that's not to say that they're
not useful it's not to say they're not
informative it's not to say that the
people using them
are doing a poor job
but muscle protein synthesis is by
definition not
hypertrophy
and whenever we look at something a
proxy measure protein quality protein
digestibility muscle protein synthesis
amino acid composition we can use that
information but we have to contextualize
it and use it very carefully and we have
to continuously cross reference that
with applied studies when they're
available actual longitudinal designs
and there's actually a fantastic review
paper that just came out
and the review paper the title is making
sense of muscle protein synthesis a
focus on muscle growth during resistance
training so
this was one of those things i was
starting to feel like a conspiracy
theorist how i would i got to the point
where people would ask me about like hey
what's up with this muscle protein
synthesis thing and i'd be like
yeah i just don't think that has
anything to do with hypertrophy you know
um well so i i remember um
a question that i used to field somewhat
frequently after um
god i forget who the lead author on it
was but there was a pretty influential
narrative review that came out that that
was just about like
uh nutritional things to optimize muscle
protein synthesis and lifters and one of
the things that it said was for healthy
young people
muscle protein synthesis seems to be
maximized with a protein bolus of 0.25
grams per kilogram which if you weigh 80
kilograms would be like 20 grams of
protein or something like that and then
i think uh the paper also recommended
four or five uh
protein boluses per day right to
to uh get you the protein you need and
not uh
compact it too much so you might run
into like the muscle full effect and
stuff like that refractory periods yeah
things like that yeah so
you put those two pieces of information
together and we were just arguing that
you know maybe you can get away with
down to about 1.2 grams per kilo of
protein but
the the bulk of the research does still
suggest that if you want to be better
safe than sorry one point optimize
rather than do good enough exactly right
something like 1.6 2.2 something
somewhere in that range tens tends to
get you where you want to go um but yeah
if you look at
the the data there the acute muscle
protein synthesis stuff and the number
of protein boluses per day you would say
like oh somewhere between 1 and 1.25
grams of protein per kilo of body mass
that should maximize hypertrophy which
does
conflict to some degree with the
longitudinal evidence and so people
people would ask me about that and
they'd be like well what what should
what should i put more stock in this
muscle protein synthesis stuff or the
longitudinal study outcomes and i said i
don't know man like call me a rube but
if i want to know about building muscle
i'm going to look at the studies that
actually
assess building muscle over time so
um yeah this is
i think a cyclical conversation comes up
from time to time and
uh my opinion is when you have
longitudinal studies
you uh pay more attention to the
longitudinal studies right and like i
said i was getting to the point where i
kept people would say well
you know this acute mps stuff doesn't
match up with the longitudinal stuff and
i'd say
then just go with the longitudinal stuff
you know and and the the just the title
of this new review paper kind of
uh validates that that fact that a lot
of people have been taking this
acute mechanistic muscle protein
synthesis
information and just over extrapolating
it into conditions that aren't
appropriate and making conclusions that
might not be appropriate based on the
study design based on you know one of
the big things that that comes up with
these studies just to put some degree of
specificity into the conversation is
like
if you're doing
a single bout of unaccustomed exercise
exercise and you're looking at immediate
muscle protein synthesis response
that's going to correlate very poorly
with long-term hypertrophy potential
there's just too much muscle damage
going on it's you're not getting a good
snapshot so there are instances where
this muscle protein synthesis data
can correlate much better with long-term
longitudinal outcomes it's usually uh
people that are not doing unaccustomed
to exercise people that are not totally
untrained and you know engaging in
training for the first time uh
measurements taken over longer time
courses rather than just a few hours
looking at a snapshot there so
once again i don't want to discredit the
research that's been done on most muscle
protein synthesis it's
valuable research it's informative but
when we have instances where it totally
contradicts more applied longitudinal
research um i'm more inclined to go with
the longitudinal stuff not to say it's
perfect you know a lot of the
measurement techniques that we use uh
for
muscle building over you know 8-12 weeks
you could argue those aren't perfectly
sensitive so maybe we have to have some
caveats there as well but
getting back to the initial question
you know when someone says hey should i
bump up my protein if i'm lifting and
i'm you know really lean and really
restricting
i'd say man
our good friend uh the good dr helms did
a pretty good systematic review
indicating that in those situations
protein probably ought to be bumped up a
little bit and that was based on some
pretty good applied longitudinal designs
that i feel really good about so if i'm
looking at you know if i on one hand
i've got the body of literature from a
really well done systematic review on
those applied trials and on the other
i've got acute muscle protein synthesis
data
give me the first one every time you
know give me the former rather than the
latter so
uh if you want to look into that review
paper i am going to link it in the show
notes i think it's i think it's really
well done you know it points out the
issues with
longitudinal body comp assessments which
are fair it points out the
methodological considerations that could
lead to
misapplication of muscle protein
synthesis data
overall very well done and very relevant
to that question that i received